This is just a fun quiz to get you thinking
about latency and throughput. I am sure that most of
you would have gotten that, the time to get to
the classroom, after all, from my office is one minute,
so that's the latency I'm going to observe, getting to my
classroom. The interesting thing is the throughput. The throughput is
five per minute, because the hallway is wide enough. For
five of us to walk side by side, so the throughput
that we can get is five per minute. The important
thing I want you to see is that, the latency
is not the inverse of throughput. On other words, if
tomorrow I widen the hallway to make 10 people walk
side by side to get to the classroom from my
office, that's going to increase the throughput, but it does nothing
to the latency, the latency is always going to be the
time it takes for me to get from my office,
to the classroom.